ده وقد اعلانات وزاره الدفاع تايوانيه ان
احدى وسبعين طائره صينيه بين مقاتله ومسير
اخترقت منطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي للجزيره
في اكبر توقل صيني حتى الان من جهته قال
الجيش الصيني انه سيتاخذ جميع الاجراءات
اللازمه لدفاع عن سياده البلاد وسلامه
اراضيها بالتزامن اعلن الكريمن عن مباحثات
المرتقبه بين الرئيس الروسي لازم يفوتن
ونظيره الصيني جين بينج قبل نهايه العام
لانه سيتم ترديد الخدمه العسكريه
الاجباريه في تايوان من اربعه اشهر الى
عاما واحد اعتبارا من الاول من يناير عام
2020 وذلك لتعزيز السعدان القتاليه ضد
الهجمات الصينيه المحتمله
للمجاهدين من الراتب المبدئين الحالي
للتاكد من انهم يكسبون ما يكفي لتغطيه
نفقتهم اليوميه الاساسيه ومع ذلك حضر
الخبراء من ان تنفيذ البرنامج قد يكون
صعبا نظرا لافتقار تايوان لضباط لتدريب
المجندين ونقص الموارد والتسهيلات اللازمه
لتوسيع الانظمه التدريب
وفي اول رد فعل الامريكيين قال متحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ان الولايات
المتحده تشعر بالقلق اذا ما وصفها بالنشاط
العسكري الاستفزازي للصين بالقرب من
تايوان
ويخاطر بالوقوع في حسابات خاطئه ويقود
السلامه والاستقرار الاقليميين
الولايات المتحده
ان الاداره الامريكيه ستستمر في تقديم
الدعم تايوان وتحافظ على القدره الكافيه
للدفاع عن نفسها بما يتماشا مع التزاماتنا
التزاماتها طويله الامد وبما يتفق مع
سياسه الصين واحده
معنى الان من بيجين مدير مكتب الجزيره
ناصر عبد الحق نرحب بك ناصر ما بين هذه
التغييرات والخطوات الصينيه وردود الفعل
الامريكي التي تراها خاطئه كيف تبدو
الصوره اليك
المتحده في يعني بيانها الصادر عن مجلس
الامن القومي عندما تقول انها قلقه من
التحركات الصينيه بالقرب من جزيره تايوان
الصين في المقابل تعبر او عبرت عن غضب
وليس قلق من التصرفات الامريكيه اتجاه
قضيه جزيره تايوان وذلك من خلال هذه
الصفقات التي تعقدها الولايات المتحده
التي تنوي من خلالها تزويد تايوان
مليارات الدولارات من الاسلحه المتقدمه
وذلك كما تقول الصينيه
الاساسيه التي قامت عليها العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه في سبعينيات القرن
الماضي
وترفضها جمله وتفصيلا
ايضا علينا ملاحظه ردود افعال الصين خلال
السنوات الماضيه على كل ما يمس كما تقول
سيادتها على اراضيها راينا الصين او ردود
افعال الصين كيف كانت تجاه التحركات في
جزيره هونج كونج او شبه جزيره هونج وما
قامت به الصين على اثر ذلك والان نرى
الصين كيف ترد على ما تقوم به ااه ااه
القياده او الحكومه في تايوان والتي
تصرفها الصين
بالانفصاليه ودعم الولايات المتحده لها
ايضا الصين تبدي ابتعاضها من سياسه
الولايات المتحده في مما يتعلق بقضيه
تايوان فبينما تقول الولايات المتحده
بانها تدعم صين واحده تقول الصين ان
تصرفات الولايات المتحده لا تشير الى ذلك
همم وذلك من خلال
الزيارات التي يقوم بها
همم عده مسؤولون او مسؤولين امريكيين الى
الجزيره خلال العوامل الماضيه او من خلال
تقديم الدعم العسكري والمعنوي ايضا من قبل
الولايات المتحده للحكومه القائمه في
جزيره تايوان المناورات او الاختراق
العسكري الصيني الاخير من قصص الطائرات
والسفن الصينيه حول الجزيره همم هو الاوسع
من نوعه منذ المناورات العسكريه التي قامت
بها الصين بعيده زياره همم رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي نانسي بوليسي الى الجزيره
قبل عده اشهر اذا الصين كما قالت وتقول
دائما في موضوع قضيه تايوان بالنسبه اليها
هو خط احمر وسيكون رد الصين قوي على اي
تحركات تشير به همم النزعه الانفصاليه
للجزيره نعم ين مدير مكتب الجزيره ناصر
عبد الحق